des arrêtés autorisant la réouverture
des commerces non essentiel en plein
confinement voilà la décision prise par
certains élus outrepassé la loi
cet acte de résistance a un nom la
désobéissance civile je pratique la
désobéissance civile des élus qui ne
respectent pas la loi
ce n'est pas nouveau l'un des premiers
cas médiatisés c'était françois
mitterrand 1979 à l'époque l'état exerce
un monopole sur la radio et la
télévision les radios libres sont
interdites mais le premier secrétaire du
parti socialiste enfreint la loi et
lance une émission pirates depuis les
locaux du ps
radio riposte nous voulons absolument
attirer l'attention des français sur les
manquements sur les atteinte à un droit
fondamental qui est celui de
l'information
six minutes après le début de l'émission
la radio est brouillé la police envahi
les lieux les radios libres sont
autorisés en 1981 année d'arrivée de la
gauche au pouvoir
autre cas de désobéissance civile celui
de jeannette gaschard maire de mayronnes
dans l'aude en 1997 motif de sa colère
la loi debré qui oblige chaque français
à fournir un certificat à la mairie si
les berges à l'étranger je me vois mal
moi j'ai un frère keith au zaïre s'il
vient avec des amis je me vois mal lui
dire écoute tes amis faut que je les
enregistre en mairie sous la pression de
la gauche le texte change quelques jours
après
sept ans plus tard en 2004 nouveaux cas
de désobéissance civile de la part d'un
élu cette fois c'est noël mamère maire
de bègles en gironde qui enfreint la loi
très ému il célèbre le premier mariage
homosexuel pourtant interdite en france
je pense qu'aujourd'hui nous faisons et
je pense qu'aujourd'hui nous faisons un
geste en direction de la france cet acte
de désobéissance civile aura des
conséquences noël mamère est suspendu de
sa fonction pendant un mois et le
mariage est annulé
il faut attendre 2013 pour que la loi
autorise le mariage homosexuel est là
aussi certains élus ne la respecte pas à
l'image du maire d'arcangues dans les
pyrénées atlantiques qui refusent d'unir
guy et jean michel à partir du moment où
on demande de cautionner par un mariage
qui est une parodie on sait bien qu'il
n'y a pas d'égalité du tout c'est un
gros mensonge
où est l'égalité d'un couple qui peut
pas s'ériger d'un couple qu'il faut
faire des enfants en cas de refus
d'appliquer la loi
les sanctions sont lourdes un an
d'inéligibilité
trois ans d'emprisonnement et 45000
euros d'amendé pour cet élu finalement
le mariage est célébré rapidement par un
adjoint du maire
[Musique]